If you’ve ever been to London, or even seen
a picture of London, you’ve probably seen
the giant clock tower at the corner of the
Palace of Westminster. This tower is one of
London’s major icons, ranking right up there
with red double-decker buses, the London Eye,
and Platform 9 ¾.
Contrary to popular belief, the clock tower
itself is not named “Big Ben”. Rather,
it is named “Elizabeth Tower”, after Queen
Elizabeth II; named such during her Diamond
Jubilee (the 2012 60th anniversary of her
accession to the throne). Before that, it
was just called “Clock Tower”. So why
is it so often called “Big Ben”? That
is due to the great bell inside the tower
that chimes the hour out and goes by that
name. Over time this has morphed into many
calling the clock tower itself that even today,
despite the recent, very public, name change.
So how did “Big Ben”- the great bell-
get its name? People seemed to be in the habit
of nicknaming giant bells and Big Ben was
one of the biggest in the world and the largest
in the British Isles at the time of its casting,
so certainly name-worthy. The origin of Big
Ben’s name is probably rooted in Sir Benjamin
Hall. Hall was reportedly a large man (6 ft.
4 in. or 1.93 m, with a girth to match) and
was the first Commissioner of Works, affectionately
known as “Big Ben.”
On the side of the great bell there was also
supposedly the inscription “Sir Benjamin
Hall MP Chief Commissioner of Works” in
his honor, so the workers and others took
to calling the bell “Big Ben”.
If you’re wondering why that text is not
inscribed there anymore (if it ever truly
was), it’s because the current Big Ben is
not the original. The original bell actually
cracked before the clock itself was even installed
in the tower (more on this later). As to why
the name supposedly was inscribed on the first
and not the second bell, the reason often
given is that Sir Hall was no longer the Chief
Commissioner when the second bell was cast.
In addition, different founders were used
to cast the second bell, so they may not have
felt inclined to put the inscription on.
As there is little documented evidence on
the origin of the name “Big Ben”, we can’t
say for 100% certainty that it was named after
Sir Benjamin Hall. Another possibility that
has been proposed is that it was named after
Benjamin Caunt, a very popular heavyweight
boxing champion in the 1850s, who was also
nicknamed “Big Ben”.
Yet another popular theory is that it was
named in 1857 during a sitting of the House
of Commons. At some point someone, tired of
the long meeting over the naming of the great
bell, just shouted “Why not call it Big
Ben?” as a joke while Sir Benjamin Hall
was talking. However, if such a thing actually
happened, there should be Parliament records
of this, but there is not. Thus, it’s thought
the original Hall inscription story is more
likely; though in both that story and the
Parliament story, it was named after Sir Hall
who was integrally connected with the building
of the tower, clock, and bells.
As to why the clock tower was built in the
first place, in 1834, a fire destroyed the
Palace of Westminster—then the seat of the
British government—leaving only a few parts
of the palace standing. The next year, with
reconstruction well on its way, Parliament
opted to include a clock tower in the redesign.
It wasn’t the first clock tower that the
parliament buildings had seen. The first one
was built between 1288 and 1290 and contained
a bell known as “Great Edward” or “Great
Tom.” A second tower, containing the first
public chiming clock in England, replaced
the first in 1367. In 1707, that tower was
demolished because it had fallen into disrepair.
Instead of replacing the tower with another,
a sundial was put up in its place.
After the fire, Sir Charles Barry’s design
for the new Houses of Parliament was chosen
out of 97 designs submitted for consideration-
his design didn’t originally include a clock
tower. He added one in 1836 and later drew
up a detailed design with the help of Augustus
Pugin. Pugin was never recognized by Barry
for supplying the design for the clock, despite
Pugin saying, “I never worked so hard in
my life as for Mr. Barry for tomorrow I render
all the designs for finishing his bell tower
& it is beautiful…”
The tower was Pugin’s last design. In 1852,
before work on the tower was completed, Pugin
suffered a breakdown. He was unable to speak
coherently or recognize his family, and died
several months later despite attempted therapy.
He was only forty years old and never knew
how famous his last design would become.
Construction on the tower began September
28, 1843. It was built from the inside out
so that scaffolding couldn’t be seen by
passers-by.
Besides Pugin’s work, Sir Charles Barry
also sought additional help when it came to
the actual clock mechanism itself. He chose
Benjamin Lewis Vuillamy, who was the Queen’s
clockmaker, to work on a design, though other
clockmakers were also brought in to give their
advice and opinions. In 1846, a competition
was held to see who would build the clock,
but some amazingly tough standards- for the
age- were set by the Astronomer Royal, Sir
George Airy. Airy stated that the clock needed
to strike the hour within one second’s accuracy,
and the performance of the clock was to be
telegraphed to the Greenwich Observatory twice
daily. This harsh criteria caused seven years
of delay.
When Edward John Dent was finally appointed
to build the clock in 1852, he found that
the tower was too small for the initial clock
design. This caused further delays and alterations
had to be made to the tune of £100 (adjusted
for inflation by average earnings, that’s
about £69,000 today). To top it all off,
after finally getting construction underway,
Dent died the next year and his stepson had
to take over. The clock was finally finished
in 1854, costing a total of £2500 to make.
The clock’s delay didn’t end up mattering
very much, as the clock tower itself had suffered
delays as well. The clock wasn’t actually
installed until 1859. During the two-year
wait, modifications were made to meet the
Astronomer Royal’s standards. For instance,
Edmund Beckett Denison invented a “Double
Three-Legged Gravity Escapement” for the
clock which made sure that the pendulum wasn’t
affected by wind or other external factors
putting pressure on the clock’s hands. Also
known as the Grimthorpe Escapement, this revolutionary
invention is still used on many clocks throughout
the world today.
When the clock was finally installed in April
1859, it didn’t work. The original cast
iron hands were too heavy to keep time and
had to be replaced by lighter copper hands.
At last, on May 31, 1859, the clock began
successfully keeping time. But the tower wasn’t
yet completed—it also needed a bell.
Like the rest of the features of the tower,
the great bell also suffered delays. The first
great bell was cast in 1856 and hung in the
New Palace Yard where it was tested every
day. On October 17, 1857, as mentioned previously,
a crack over a metre long appeared on the
bell. Fingers were pointed, but no one fessed
up. Because the original bell casters—the
Warners—asked for too much to replace the
bell, the Whitechapel Foundry got the job
for the replacement. The second bell weighed
2.5 tonnes less than the first (13.5 tons
instead of 16), but it was still so large
that it took thirty hours to winch it up to
the belfry in the tower.
At last, on July 11, 1859, Big Ben rang out
for the first time. Unfortunately, in September
of that year, a crack appeared in the bell
again. This time supposedly because the hammer
used to strike it was approximately two times
the maximum weight the original bell founder
specified for the bell. This crack caused
the great bell to remain silent for a few
years. However, in 1863, Airy came up with
a solution: turn the bell so that the hammer
struck a different spot, make the hammer lighter,
and cut a small square in the bell so that
the crack wouldn’t spread. His solution
worked, and to this day, the same cracked
“Big Ben” sits in the belfry, ringing
away on
the hour.